STEVE JAMISON: Brad,
this is your kind
of place-- Google, informal.
BRAD GILBERT: Very informal.
You know, I learned
to work in my shorts.
I like to see that everybody--
there's bright people here,
but it's not about
wearing a suit and tie.
STEVE JAMISON: It's
very good, yeah.
This is informal
Friday, but I've
got a feeling the rest of
the week's about the same
as far as dress.
Now, that first clip
we saw before Agassi,
you tell me that was you?
BRAD GILBERT: That was me, yeah.
You know, what's funny
is back in the mid '80s,
you think you're hip when
you're wearing tight shorts,
you're wearing high socks.
I had the bad kind of
fro-mullet type thing.
But as I've gotten older,
now it's like long shorts,
it's like no socks,
and the hair is tight.
It's funny when you
see those old clips.
What's funny is, many, the older
I get, the better I used to be.
STEVE JAMISON: Yeah.
Well, you look pretty good,
but you made a comment
about the speed of the
game back then and now.
BRAD GILBERT: Well, do you
remember about the first time
that you used the internet?
It was like a dial-up, and
you had to use the phone,
and it would kill
the line or whatever.
That's kind of how it
looks when you see tennis
from the '80s, amazing how
much faster they're playing
and how much more athletic
the game has become.
STEVE JAMISON: Well, I want
to ask you some questions,
and we're going to take a lot
of questions from the audience
here and watching.
But when you were playing,
some amazing things happened.
You rose to number four
in the world at one point.
You were ranked number four.
The reason I say "amazing"
is because nobody
expected you to really be
an outstanding, great pro.
Your mother told me
when we were working
on "Winning Ugly,"
I said, what did
you think Brad's prospects were
when he got out of high school?
And she said, we thought he'd
get a job flipping burgers.
She was being a
little facetious,
but she didn't think you'd get
to number four in the world.
How high in the rankings-- what
was your own self-- evaluation?
BRAD GILBERT: When
I was a little kid,
my dad took me to
a Davis Cup match
when I was like nine years old
at Round Hill Country Club,
and he said, you're
playing Davis Cup,
and you're going to be
a pro tennis player.
So I kind of always
thought, OK, he must know.
That's what I'm going to do.
For me, my entire tennis
career changed just
in a short period of time
in early January of 1980
when I went to Foothill
Junior College, which
is very close to here,
and I met a coach named
Tom Chivington, who explained
things very simplistically,
made the approach to
the game a lot more fun.
And I felt like in that
short period of time--
also, for some reason, I grew
six inches in about six weeks,
which really helped.
But that's where things
really clicked in for me.
I never really thought about
where I was going to go.
Just for me, the whole thing was
about the journey to get better
and just to see
where I could go.
I think part of it
is just never being
satisfied with where you are.
STEVE JAMISON: When we were
working on "Winning Ugly,"
I interviewed Coach Chivington.
I said, what did
you see in Brad that
was good enough to get him to
your college and your coaching?
And he said, it was
a very funny thing.
I scouted him in
three or four matches.
He said, there's
a check-off list
that you go through when
you're watching a player.
I'd watch Brad, and there's
a check-off for forehand.
No forehand.
No back hand.
Overhead?
Shaky.
Second serve?
None.
And he said at the bottom of the
page, he wrote, but Brad wins.
And that goes to the whole
secret of your success,
in a sense, and it's what
the book is all about.
There's not a single
stroke tip here.
It's all about the secret of
winning ugly, which is mental.
It's the mental
skill that you had
that was, in my view, your
strongest weapon and stronger
than any of the others out
there at the time, the guys
you were playing.
Lendl had the big
forehand, the big backhand.
You had it up here.
Can you expand on that a little?
BRAD GILBERT: Well,
to me, I always
feel like as a tennis
player and in my coaching,
you've got to learn to be honest
with yourself what you do well,
what you don't do well,
and try to maximize
what you're doing out there.
You know, I think a lot
about what I'm trying to do,
but I try not to completely
kill myself when it's over.
I feel like the most important
thing is that you give 100%.
You compete, you love
what you're doing,
and you try to
figure out how you
can maximize what you're doing.
And basically, to be
honest with you, that's
all I was thinking I was doing.
People would say that I'm
overachieving all the time,
and I'd kind of
look at them, why?
That's what your expectation
is because I'm overachieving.
I actually don't think I am.
I think I can do better.
STEVE JAMISON: The
whole book is nothing
but golden nuggets of
how to maximize yourself
as a tennis player.
One of the things you
said in our conversations
was my whole goal is to
make the opponent beat me
with his weakest shots.
And figuring that out, of
course, is the challenge,
and then making him hit those
shots is what you did so well.
BRAD GILBERT: You know,
what's funny is the difference
between playing and coaching.
I had my thoughts and
styles how I played.
When I started
coaching Andre, it's
amazing how, when you look
through someone else's lens,
that things can be a
little bit different.
Immediately, if I thought a
guy had a really good weapon,
I was like, oh man, I'm
going to stay away from that.
And then when I would tell
Andre about a weakness,
he'd want to know
about the strength
because he goes, I want to go
right through their strength,
because he goes, you
break down their strength,
man, you just break
everything down.
Mentally, they're gone.
I'm like, man, I'm
just not good enough
to be thinking about doing that.
But it's amazing
how you can take
two guys, two different
lenses, and get
completely different views.
STEVE JAMISON: You obviously
got him to your way of thinking.
He won seven Grand Slams
with you, didn't he?
BRAD GILBERT: He did, yeah.
STEVE JAMISON:
And so did you get
him to exploit weakness more
and more as you guys went along?
BRAD GILBERT: The
biggest thing that I
thought when I
started with Andre,
I just told him very simply
that no matter what he did,
it could always be better.
And his dad always
said no matter
what it was, it could
always be better.
And I told him the pursuit
of perfection doesn't exist.
It only makes you miserable
trying to chase it.
And I said, you've just got
to learn to be good enough.
You are so talented,
but yet you're
always trying to be perfect,
which is costing you
a lot of matches.
I just told him, a
lot of times, you just
need meat and potatoes.
You just need to be at 60%
and not hitting for the lines,
not thinking about
winning one and love.
STEVE JAMISON: Where was he
in the rankings when you guys
teamed up as coach and player?
BRAD GILBERT: In
1994 when we started,
we were playing a tournament
together in Miami,
and I was, I want to think,
about 22, 23 in the rankings,
and he was about
28 in the rankings,
so he was about
five spots below me.
STEVE JAMISON: That's
ironic, isn't it,
because this is one of the
greatest tennis players ever.
Would you rank him in
the top five, Andre?
BRAD GILBERT: In the
open air, I probably
would put him right about there.
A year from the day when
I started coaching him,
he went from 28 to 1.
And once again, on
that, when I coach,
I don't think about numbers.
I just think about the journey,
the process of getting better.
I remember when I was coaching
Kei Nishikori in 2011,
and the Japanese
media kept asking,
when is he going to be this?
When is he going to be that?
It's like any time
that you think
that you have do something,
it puts more pressure on you,
and the journey is in a player.
We're going to try to improve.
We're going to
try to get better.
We're going to work
hard, and we're
going to try to
make things happen.
But if you put some undue number
and time frame on something,
it's going to make you
more conscious of it,
and then that's going
to become the focus.
STEVE JAMISON: We're going
to take some questions here
in just a second, but
as you probably know,
Brad is, in the
opinion of most people,
the top analyst on
television today.
At ESPN, he does all
of the Grand Slams
and a bunch of
other tournaments.
And so you know modern tennis
as well as anyone out there.
On the men's side, who
out there in the top 10
do you think you could
help the most as a coach?
Or don't you want the answer
getting back to the player?
BRAD GILBERT: I mean, life
would be easy right now
if you just rocked up and then
you were coaching Djokovic.
He's on auto-pilot.
I mean, how good would
it have been the last 10
years to be Fed's coach?
To me, right now,
we're in an era
of seeing so quickly after
the Andre/Pete thing,
that you would think, OK, maybe
there would be a little time
frame there would have
been some jockeying,
but it's amazing how
quickly we got Fed, and then
Nadal, now Djokovic, Murray.
To me, I've never seen
better athleticism
in the game, better
all-around movement.
And the skill set-- I was
sitting courtside in Miami
and watching the way
that Djokovic moves.
I couldn't believe
what he was able to do,
his ability to stop on
a dime, be able to go,
to be able to find angles
and movements in his body.
It's incredible.
And I'm one of
these people that I
feel like the modern
game is like a moving
escalator at the airport.
You get off of it,
it keeps going.
And I think 20 years from
now, we'll continue to grow.
And I'm not one of these people
that we want to go backwards.
I just was in an
event in Houston,
and I saw an older player.
He was a great player.
He's in his late 70s.
He just was harping on me
about the volley's dead,
and why don't we do this,
and he hates the modern game.
And the first thing I said to
him was-- he could barely walk.
His knees were shot.
His hips were gone.
It's like, all the serving and
volleying has ruined your body.
And I was like, I really
enjoy this modern game.
He goes, I hear you talk about
that crap all the time on TV.
Go back to like we
played in the '50s.
I was like, no, I don't want
to go back to that time.
And I think that we're
constantly evolving and getting
better.
That's what you guys are
doing here every day.
STEVE JAMISON: Is Serena
the best ever in women's?
BRAD GILBERT: She's
right there now.
I think the two
best female athletes
I've seen in my lifetime are
both female tennis players,
are Steffi Graf and
Serena Williams.
STEVE JAMISON: You like Steffi?
BRAD GILBERT: And I think that
Serena is right on the edge,
and she's probably
the best tennis
player in the
history of the game,
male or female, at her
age, at 33, almost 34.
She's had the three
most dominant years,
and she's become a
great player in her 30s.
Her longevity is
amazing, considering she
won her first slam
at 17, and she's now
half that older,
almost 34, and still
playing maybe better than ever.
I asked her a question in Miami,
and she actually got stumped.
I said, is Serena
Williams better
now than she was 10 years ago?
Who would win?
And then she said immediately,
oh no, Serena 10 years ago
would win.
She got a little bit rattled.
Then that night, I
happened to see her,
and she told me she
had been thinking
about it for a few hours after
she just blurted it out on TV.
And she said that she was a lot
better, she felt like, at 33
than she was at 23 because a
33-year-old Serena, she said,
was a lot more adaptable.
She'd studied the
game a lot more
and didn't rely as much
on her athleticism,
and she was embracing technology
that she never did then.
She didn't scout her opponents.
So she said that maybe
athletically, she
wasn't quite as good, but
she was a way smarter player.
STEVE JAMISON: If you
were playing today
as a young Brad Gilbert, you're
24, 25 years old, how would
you do?
BRAD GILBERT: I mean, we're
all brassed into think
that we'd be good.
I mean, obviously, I would
have to make some changes,
but I still think I could be OK.
I don't know what level,
but I'm sure that I
could get a paycheck.
STEVE JAMISON: Yes, I think
you could get a paycheck.
BRAD GILBERT: I
don't know that I
would have got to four
with as good as they are,
but I would sure
as heck be trying.
I know that the
biggest difference
between now and
when I was playing
is that athletes
are living 24/7.
There's no off season--
the diet, the training.
I didn't exactly do the hard
core training that these guys--
STEVE JAMISON: No, you were not.
I knew you then.
You were not the hard core
trainer that you later became.
BRAD GILBERT: I eat kale now
all the time, and I eat lentils.
I had beans for lunch.
I don't eat anything fried.
My diet's 50 times better.
I wish I was reborn and
had a better diet then.
STEVE JAMISON: Skill-wise,
you would have done good.
BRAD GILBERT: I think
I would have been OK.
I don't know how good,
but maybe coaching
is a better thing for me.
STEVE JAMISON: Listen.
I'll tell you
something about Brad,
and I've said this in
front of him before.
He hit the trifecta of skills.
As a tennis player,
he got to number four.
As a coach, they
said on the air when
he was coaching Andre and
this tremendous ascent,
Brad is the best tennis
coach in the world.
That's what many thought.
And now on ESPN, number one.
It's tremendous how you've
gone from one to the other
and succeeded.
Before we take a
question, for anybody
that doesn't know
what "winning ugly"
means in the context of
sports particularly, but life,
can you give it your
definition, how it applies?
BRAD GILBERT: For me, it's all
about finding a way to compete
and not thinking it
has to be done one way.
To me, speaking of
winning ugly, you
know that we've gone
to another level.
About two weeks ago, the
"Evening Standard" newspaper
in London-- you ever
heard of this paper?
They have a politician
now in London.
They were calling--
Kimmie, what was his name?
My wife will maybe
know his name,
but they were calling
this politician,
"he is winning ugly in
politics in London."
There was a giant article
comparing him to me.
STEVE JAMISON: No.
BRAD GILBERT: Honest
to God that they
were saying that he has
no skills of a politician,
he has no this, he has no that.
And the entire time,
they kept comparing him
like 20 different times, but
yet he wins the election.
STEVE JAMISON: There
you are-- no skills,
no forehand, no backhand.
He's going to win the election.
Well, quickly, we were talking
about the Mayweather fight,
and you said about
Floyd, he's what?
BRAD GILBERT: To me,
I'm a huge boxing fan
because there are quite a few
parallels in a one-on-one sport
that there are in tennis,
and I like the strategy
that one person's trying
to implement to the other.
And when I watch
Floyd Mayweather,
because everyone
thinks about the money
and his incredible persona,
he's the all time winning ugly.
STEVE JAMISON: Explain that.
BRAD GILBERT: To me, because
when you as a boxing fan
or you watch boxing, you're
thinking, where's the knockout?
Where's the pizazz?
He never gets hit.
He's a defensive genius.
He doesn't knock guys out.
He outpoints you.
And a lot of times, you hear
the pundits talking about him.
His fights are ugly to
watch because he's boring.
He wins.
He doesn't hit you that
much and doesn't get hit.
I'm thinking, man, he's
figured something out.
He's not getting hit.
He's pointing you to death,
and he's boring everybody.
So that means he must be
doing something genius-like
because you can't figure
out what he's doing.
STEVE JAMISON: So your pick?
BRAD GILBERT: Mayweather,
an easy, unanimous decision.
STEVE JAMISON: No knockout?
BRAD GILBERT: No.
It'll be, like,
10 rounds to two.
He doesn't want to knock
him out because then he can
have another rematch with him.
STEVE JAMISON: The
whole back section just
left to place bets
with their bookies,
so let's take some questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
STEVE JAMISON:
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: My name is
Salim, and I really
love talking about coaching.
So with my son, I
don't think he'll
be playing in the
professional leagues,
but I'm trying to get him
to think about-- I love when
he's at bat, he gets a strike.
He just lets it go, gets
back in, and hits the ball.
But I'm trying to translate
this onto his schoolwork,
and sometimes he
does bad on a test.
I'm trying to go,
think about how do you
do it when you get a strike?
You get back in there,
you hit the ball
without-- I watched him
play and I was like,
wow, how do you do that?
I can't get him to translate
into his other work.
For me, like many other
parents, his schoolwork
is much more which
I'm focusing on.
Any tips?
BRAD GILBERT: It's an
interesting question.
I was probably like your son
that I was really focused.
Back in the day, when we
didn't have no cable TV,
everything was about
playing sports.
But obviously,
there's a balance.
Education is a huge thing.
We all wish we could be great
athletes and be pro athletes,
but having knowledge
is a great thing.
And unfortunately, at school,
you are judged by a number.
But to me, I think a lot of
our coaches here in the States,
and I'm sure a lot of
places around the world,
we're obsessed in every sport
when somebody comes through,
you have to do it this
way to become a pro.
And I'm about, let's
learn to enjoy it.
Use the life skills,
especially like tennis.
It's something you can do
for the rest of your life.
It can help you.
Just because you
don't become a pro,
but maybe it will help
you in your life skills,
or it will help you in your job.
Try to do fun little games
with your kid about schoolwork.
We're not going
to go from, let's
say, if he's getting
30% to 90%, but let's
do games or do something
to make it fun,
and don't stress him about
if he's not doing great,
but we can do better.
AUDIENCE: We have
several initiatives
around meditation, mindfulness.
There's lots of stories
of Phil Jackson applying
that kind of thing to the
MBA teams he worked with,
the flow state,
being in the zone.
I'm curious did you do
any of those practices?
Did you and Andre work on that?
What advice do you have?
BRAD GILBERT: It's
a good question.
Myself, I didn't do anything.
I think I was my
own sports shrink.
But I just thought
about a lot myself,
the plan, what I was going to
do, and if it didn't go well.
And so I was always thinking
about just game plan.
I remember one time, one
of the craziest things
I did in my entire life,
I completely panicked.
There was an older tennis player
whose name was Brian Teacher,
and he was way into
meditation and all sorts
of things like yoga and all
sorts of things in the '80s I
didn't know about.
And he had at his place
called a salt tank,
and it was like this
coffin that was in water,
and you floated, and
they locked you in.
And he said, you go in
there for about 20 minutes,
and you just get into
deep meditation and think.
I think 20 seconds afterwards,
I was pounding on the door
that I have got to get out.
I was panicking.
It just was not for me.
And then when I started coaching
Andre, I didn't really think.
I translated to the
things that I understood,
but I did understand
the one thing is now
you're looking through
somebody else's lens.
I'm probably positive
beyond belief.
I'm probably annoying
about how positive we're
going to find
something positive,
so I probably have
a little sports
psychology in my coaching
without having any training.
But no, I've never done any
meditation or visualized.
Sometimes people think,
visualize winning.
No, you've got to let
it flow a little bit.
And I'll give you a
question about Phil Jackson.
I saw him in Australia one time,
and I had a little conversation
with him.
And I asked him,
I said, how often
do you go to dinner
with Kobe and Jack?
And he looked at me,
he said straight up,
he goes, excuse me?
And I said, how often,
away from practice,
do you go to dinner with
these guys, the two of them
or separately?
Or how often do you go
with Michael Jordan?
He's like, never.
And I said, what
do you mean never?
He goes, team function,
practice, then we
go our separate ways, or I
give them a book or something
to read.
I was like, really?
I said, when I was
coaching Andre,
we probably went to
dinner six nights a week,
and I said, probably the
best coaching that I did
was at dinner in a relaxed
setting going over strategy.
And I said, sometimes that's
where you can throw out a hook
and find out where you're
going to go with it.
If he doesn't give
you something,
you know to back off,
and then all of a sudden,
if he is biting on
it a little bit,
you know which area you can go.
But I feel like that's the most
relaxed, easy time to coach,
and he wasn't buying it at all.
STEVE JAMISON: How do
you like the Warriors?
How deep will the Warriors
go in the playoffs?
BRAD GILBERT: Well,
it's been since 1976,
the '75-76 season since we
got to the conference finals,
so I'm very patient.
It's been 40 years.
I think that we've
got a very good draw.
I like our chances
against Memphis.
I'm saying that we will beat
Memphis four games to one,
and let's go from there.
That will get us
in the semifinals.
STEVE JAMISON: OK, good.
BRAD GILBERT: But I won't wear a
yellow T-shirt that we believe.
I'll be there Sunday, and I'll
be wearing a black T-shirt.
STEVE JAMISON: And you're
doing some profiles
in broadcast form, right?
BRAD GILBERT: Well, I did a
little bit of SportsCenter
for them, and I did
quite a bit of radio
in December, branching out,
doing a little football
and basketball.
And so hopefully,
I'm going to be
doing a couple spots
next week on SportsCenter
about the Doves.
But hopefully I can do a
little bit of bluffing,
but I do know the
team pretty well.
STEVE JAMISON: You're good.
AUDIENCE: My name is Mike.
Being a Canadian, I want to
ask about two fellow Canadians,
Milos and Genie.
On Milos's front, do you think
he can evolve from where he is?
Can his movement improve?
Can he improve or is
his serve just the thing
and that's what
he's going to do?
And on the Genie
front, is she done?
Has her attitude
gotten the best of her?
She's dropping, and
she can't seem to win.
What would you do with her?
BRAD GILBERT: Let's
start with Milos.
Let's start with the upside
first of your question.
I like to think sometimes in
tennis there's simple numbers,
and numbers can
tell a big story.
To me, Milos is at sixth in the
world, and he's kind of-- I'm
not going to say in
a holding pattern,
but if you look at his numbers,
he's got an amazing serve,
but his return game,
his numbers are low.
And to be able to
knock on the door
where he's going to be able to
beat a Djokovic or beat a Fed
or beat a Nadal and win
one of these things,
he's got to improve.
He's breaking it
like 11% of the time,
and it's actually down
from a couple years ago
when it was 13, 14.
He holds 94% of the time.
But when he plays those
top three or four guys,
he doesn't hold at
94% of the time.
Maybe it's a little less, and
actually, his break numbers
come down.
But he's going to have
to improve his break
number to where he can be
able to break at least 20%
of the time to win majors.
There's a potential.
He's almost 24, so
his time frame is now.
Obviously, Federer's
getting older,
Nadal is getting older,
Djokovic in his prime.
But he's been in that same
area for about 18 months.
I think it's potential,
but like I said,
I'll harp back on the return
game more than the movement,
more than anything else,
that he has to improve that.
The second part, the Genie army.
Genie Bouchard had an
amazing year last year,
an incredible year.
And sometimes in any
field that you're
in, besides tennis, beyond
business, beyond life, when
you have incredible
success, the expectation
then goes up even more.
And she signed a lot of
contracts, a lot of deals,
and then the expectation
went up even more.
And I think more than
anything, the thing
that I've noticed from her
is that she's beaten herself
up a little bit.
She's playing not relaxed.
She's playing with the pressure
that the expectation is there
for her to go to
that next level.
She signed all these big
deals, and you kind of
see it in her face a
little bit that she's
struggling with that same
enjoyment and passion.
I think she's
incredibly talented,
she's an incredible
fighter, and I think
that she will figure this out.
She needs to get back to not
worrying about-- I always say
in sports, don't worry about
what some writer's going to do.
The one thing you can control
is what happens in front of you.
Now it's a blogger, anyways.
It's not even like
a real writer.
So I think to me, for her,
she's incredibly talented,
and she has to get back
to what she was doing.
I'd go back to maybe,
if I was her coach--
she switched coaches.
Not sure that that
was a great move,
but now that's not coming back.
I'd maybe go back to
watching some of the videos
to see what she was doing when
she was playing incredibly
well to what she's doing
now and try to find out
that balance a little bit.
But for me, if she
was a stock, there's
no way I'm putting a sell
rating on a 9-- what, is she 20?
I mean, she's got time.
She's going to come back.
STEVE JAMISON: Speaking
of time, does Federer
have time to win another
Grand Slam or two,
or is he on a descent that he
can't do that at the top level?
BRAD GILBERT: It's probably the
question that I'm asked most,
and he has most hardcore
fans that I've ever
seen in all of the world.
They take everything
literally and so serious,
and if you say
something about it,
I'm telling you-- on
Twitter, I call Roger,
I call him FedFan because he and
his fans are joined at the hip.
They're so serious
about everything
that's said about him.
But he, at 33 years old,
whatever his team has done,
he never gets hurt.
He's unbelievably fit.
He's so relaxed.
I watch him play next
month at the French.
He's the only guy I've
ever seen-- he doesn't even
get any clay on his socks.
I mean, why would he
get clay on his socks?
His hair never moves.
He barely ever sweats.
STEVE JAMISON: I
never thought of that.
Yeah.
BRAD GILBERT: His RF logo
is absolutely immaculate.
Everything about him is perfect.
STEVE JAMISON: Is
the answer, then,
that he will win
one or two more?
BRAD GILBERT: You know what?
I say this, and I've
said this a lot on TV.
It irks the Fed
fans a little bit,
but I think that
he is still playing
amazing at number two in the
world, but in best of three,
he seems to play a
little better now.
But in women's tennis, take
Serena at the same age.
Women's tournaments
are best of three,
and then majors
are best of three.
In men's, the only
thing is that now you
add in it's best of five.
So the physical part can
be a little bit tougher,
and I do think that
to win a major,
he needs a little bit of help,
meaning that I'm not sure
that he can go through a Djoc or
Murray, or go through a Djoc--
beat two of those guys in
consecutive matches to win one.
So I think that
maybe to win one now,
he'd have to have
one of them lose.
I thought he would win the Open
last year when they all lost,
and surprisingly, he
lost to Cilic there,
who he had never lost to.
But that's what I think
he needs to have happen.
But he still is remarkably
in amazing shape for his age,
and I think that for 33,
is more like a 28-year-old.
AUDIENCE: There's no
American in the ATP Top 10.
What is the outlook
for the next generation
and what may be missing
that the US has not produced
a star in the last 10 years?
BRAD GILBERT: It's
a good question
that we get tired of answering.
And obviously, in the States,
we have absolutely amazing
athletes.
I mean, look at football,
basketball, and baseball,
but let's take basketball, a
guy like LeBron James or Kobe
Bryant, who I think would have
been an amazing tennis player.
But those three sports are
subsidized by the government.
They're in schools,
and a lot of times,
you don't have to leave
your area code to be
great in one of those sports.
In tennis, unfortunately, to
be great from a young age,
it takes a lot of traveling,
it takes a lot of money
to produce a great champion.
Right now on the
female side, there's
no doubt that we are getting
the best athletes in the world
on the American side to play
women's tennis because there's
not a sport in the world that's
even comparable to women's
tennis.
It's by far the biggest
sport in the world anywhere.
I believe eight of the
top nine highest grossing
female athletes in the
world are tennis players.
And obviously, in
tennis, we compete
with so many other sports.
I just did an event
yesterday for Har-Tru,
and I've been saying this
for about three years now.
For the United States
to get a lot better,
we need a lot more
kids playing on clay,
learning to play on clay.
It teaches you a
lot more discipline
and teaches you how
to build a point.
All the great Europeans
that are great
now all learned to play on
clay, and the biggest change
in my lifetime is that the
grass is way slower now.
Indoors are slower, hard courts.
So if you learn to
play on clay, it
transitions you into playing
on all other surfaces.
When I learned to play as a
kid, I played in two parks,
one called Golden
Gate Park and one
called Davie Tennis Stadium.
Golden Gate Park, you could
literally look down the court
and see a reflection of yourself
because the courts hadn't
been resurfaced in 30 years.
They're so fast, and so a
lot of the American players
learned to play on
fast courts and so many
of the courts we played on
tour were on fast courts.
That's all changed,
so I think we really
do need to embrace clay and get
it in a lot more tournaments.
I'm going to be patient.
I'm going to be hopeful.
But we do at the moment have
a great crop of about half
a dozen 17-year-old
male players,
and I'm hoping a
couple of these guys
are going to break through,
that maybe in five years,
we're going to put a buy
rating on a few of these stocks
and they're going
to be our answer.
Or five years from
now, I'll still
be talking about
on TV, god, it's
been since 2003 that
Roddick's won the Open.
It is what is.
I'm going to be
patient, but I'll
go back to that clay thing.
We need to embrace clay
a lot more in the States.
STEVE JAMISON: Give us two
names of that young group
that you're talking
about so I can go home
and google them tonight and
see a little more about them.
BRAD GILBERT:
Francis Tiafoe, who's
from College Park,
Maryland, who's 17.
He turned pro, and he signed.
He's the first tennis
client from Roc Nation.
You know what that is?
It's the new sports agency
from-- what's the rapper?
AUDIENCE: Jay-Z.
BRAD GILBERT: Jay-Z.
OK, there you go.
See?
That's above us.
STEVE JAMISON: Does
Jay-Z know Dory?
BRAD GILBERT: I'm sure he does.
But Francis Tiafoe has a
chance to be very good.
STEVE JAMISON: OK, one more.
BRAD GILBERT: Reilly Opelka.
STEVE JAMISON: From where?
BRAD GILBERT: He is from--
it's near Jacksonville
and he trains in Boca, and he's
six foot 11 as a 17-year-old,
so he's going to
be another Isner.
STEVE JAMISON: Yeah.
Can Isner win a Grand Slam?
BRAD GILBERT: Not at 30, no.
STEVE JAMISON: Can this
guy at that height?
BRAD GILBERT: You know what?
He's incredibly skillful.
He's more skillful than Isner,
way more at the same age.
But Francis Tiafoe
is more of a modern,
6'1, moves like Djokovic.
So I believe that he's our most
talented guy in a long time.
STEVE JAMISON: If they
called you and said,
we'll give you $1 million
a year to coach him,
would you quit everything
else and go to Florida?
BRAD GILBERT: That's a
big if, but you know.
STEVE JAMISON: Question.
BRAD GILBERT: Yeah,
you've been freezing him
out in the back there.
STEVE JAMISON: Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
about the training changing
since when you played.
Can you describe a
little bit about how much
time people spend off the
court and what they do?
We heard the
stories about Agassi
running hills in Vegas
in triple digit heat,
so if you can talk
a little bit more
in detail about how much time
the top players are spending
off the court in training.
BRAD GILBERT: It's
a great question.
The biggest thing
that's obviously
changed since I've been
a kid and in my lifetime,
when I was 12, if
I wasn't playing
tennis, which I
played a lot, I was
playing basketball every day.
I was playing other sports.
I was doing everything I could
to avoid going to school,
but I was playing sports.
When I was in high
school, if a guy
was the quarterback on
the team, he probably
played umpteen positions.
He was on the basketball team.
He was on the baseball team.
Everybody played
multiple sports.
But now, at 10 years old,
if somebody's playing
and they're good in
lacrosse, they play lacrosse.
If they play tennis,
they play tennis.
So many families, when
they have a kid that's
decent in one thing, they go
all in in playing one sport,
and they're training a lot more.
I mean, you go down to
Bolliterri's, and 10,
11-year-olds are in the gym
doing specific workouts.
They're on unbelievable diets.
And I'm like, man, it's
incredible the technology
that we're building.
And my first thought
is at that age
that we shouldn't be thinking
about them being pros.
Let's think about them enjoying
this journey for a lifetime,
becoming a better person,
getting education,
and then we can think about
as we get a little more
advanced to thinking about it.
But for sure, even the
kid that's really good
now in basketball
when he's 12, he's
not playing three other sports.
He's just playing basketball.
So that's the biggest thing I've
seen in the States by far is
specializing in one sport
and doing it all year round.
To your question about
Andre, as you get older,
I think you need less
time on the court and more
time in the gym.
So when Andre was probably
30, he spent a lot less time
on the court and more time
probably working on his body.
And I think when
you're 15, you need
a lot more time on the court
and probably less on the gym.
So it's specific
to what you are,
but I think you need
anything, more hours of it,
when you're a kid.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Lazlo.
So I quite recently read "The
Open" by Andre, his biography.
BRAD GILBERT: It's
a good book, huh?
AUDIENCE: It's a
great book, actually.
It's very inspirational.
And I think he quite
clearly credits you
with shifting his whole
perception of what
a challenge is in life.
So when he speaks about being
defeated by Pete Sampras
and what that does to
him psychologically,
and when you come into
the picture in the book,
suddenly anything that
gets thrown at him,
he takes it with a
totally different attitude
to say whatever doesn't
kill you makes you stronger.
So you already talked about
your innate, natural, boundless
optimism.
Besides that, did you
have any other, let's say,
life experiences or big losses
that helped frame that mindset
that you brought into
his life and made
him that kind of champion?
BRAD GILBERT: I'll tell you,
I am the beer drinking guy
who loves doing what I'm doing.
And at least in my tennis
career and my beliefs,
I had short-term memory loss.
I could get waxed.
And you know, I could be
pissed for 15 minutes,
but then I'm going to wake
up tomorrow, and it's gone.
The most important thing as
a tennis player and in life,
yesterday ain't coming back.
The only thing that
matters is tomorrow.
That's what we can
change the approach to.
And to Andre, tomorrow was--
he could beat himself up
for six months over something
that happened yesterday.
He could bite his fingers
to the bone, bite the nails.
I didn't quite understand
that whole process
how he could grind himself down
when we can learn something
from this loss and get better.
I told Andre if I
had his backhand,
that I wouldn't sleep at night.
I'd just be cashing checks.
He goes, if I had your shitty
backhand, I wouldn't sleep.
I don't think I could
make the pro tour.
But to me, I got Andre
thinking more about percentage,
because I felt like
as talented as he was,
he was trying to be too perfect
or trying to make everything
about just being at the
bar that was too high,
and sometimes, you don't
know how high the bar is
going to be.
In tennis, the
simplistic thing is
that you've just got
to be good enough
to beat the guy on the
other side of the net.
In the entire, huge
tournament, as two men enter,
one man leaves.
And you don't play
the whole draw.
You just play somebody
every other day
in a major or every
day in a tournament,
and you've got to figure out
specifically how to strategize,
how to get past that person.
And then when it's
over, what we can learn
and what we can figure out, and
the whole journey and process
opposed to having
this pre-thought.
Sometimes he could
literally work his way
into thinking that there
was no chance today
based upon how he practiced.
And I was like, how
could you work a thought
into what's going to
happen before it's even
started to happen?
But he was so intelligent.
He also blew me away.
The most incredible thing
that I was shocked about Andre
was he only went to school
until he was about 13,
and the guy is one of
the brightest people
I've ever met in my life.
He has an absolutely
photographic memory,
like scary.
He could remember every
name in the phone book.
So we started talking after the
first match that I coached him,
and I was kind of assuming
that he'd be a little bit
aloof about tennis because
of the hair and the clothes
and how he was, and
he started telling me.
When I would tell them about the
point at 4-3, how he played it,
he could remember every
single point of every rally.
He'd tell me the 17 ball rally.
This was when we
didn't have videos,
and there was no
going to YouTube,
and he could remember it.
So he challenged me
incredibly that way.
And so I think from that moment
on, I was like, you know what?
You cannot judge a
book by its cover.
But I think, to your point,
the biggest thing was I just
tried to get a little more
meat and potatoes in his game,
a little more
simplistic, and just
your talent is way good enough.
You don't have to be any
better than what you are.
STEVE JAMISON: Here's a quick
story about Andre and Brad
at the tournament at
Indian Wells right
at the height of your
collaboration on coaching
with him.
You guys were having dinner
at Ruth Chris one night
at Palm Desert, and I was
there with my parents.
They were quite old.
And I saw you over
there and I said, Dad,
I want you to meet somebody.
You were having dinner with
Andre, just the two of you.
So we come around, and
my dad had his cane
and he's walking up,
and I come around,
and you're in this big
booth, and I said, hey, Brad.
Oh, hey, Steve, how you doing?
I said, I've got somebody
that wants to meet you,
and it's my dad.
He talks to you, tells you
what a great book it is,
what a great coach you
are, turns and walks away,
and Andre's waiting, never
said a word to Andre.
Andre was good
about it, but it's
the only time that ever
happened to him where
they want to talk to you.
BRAD GILBERT: That's for sure.
STEVE JAMISON: OK.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: "Winning Ugly"
was one of the best books
on fencing that I've ever read.
BRAD GILBERT: On fencing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BRAD GILBERT: OK, I like that.
It's one on one.
See?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly,
and it changed the way
like pack your bag,
bring an extra pair
of shoes, All of the
nuggets of practical things
that you can do to
compete and get better.
What other sports do you
think "Winning Ugly" would
transfer to aside from tennis?
BRAD GILBERT: The way I think,
honestly, obviously, anything
that I see in sports,
immediately, I sometimes
look through the lens of
the player or the coach,
and I always think about--
in anything that I'm seeing.
And I'm one of the
only Americans,
early on in my career,
that I took the time
to actually understand cricket.
I like cricket.
I like soccer.
I'll watch and try to
understand any sport,
and I'm trying to think about
how, in anything that you do,
that you can maximize
your potential.
How are you going
to do what you're
going to do and do it better?
I want to know not
just on your skill set.
One of my most
frustrating things
is somebody be
amazingly athletic,
and you hear the
commentator say,
but he doesn't get
anything out of his talent.
I want the guy that's
unbelievably athletic
but gets more out of his talent.
And so that's what
I would always
think about when
somebody's doing something.
What's that little 2% or
4% that can be better?
And I imagine in
fencing and wrestling
and boxing, anything
that's one on one,
it gets my mind thinking more.
But I promise you,
whether or not
it's football,
basketball, baseball,
I'm always thinking the
same thing as the player,
as the coach.
I probably drive my
wife crazy with that
about thinking about the
strategy because I always do.
You're thinking about your bag.
I was a little crazy about that.
I would check my bag five
times just to make sure.
When you're not quite
as good as everybody,
you've got to make
sure you've got
the kitchen sink in your bag.
AUDIENCE: Here's a direct
question from Jim Young.
What pros, either on
the ATP or the WPA tour,
would you like to coach?
BRAD GILBERT: Well, life
would be really easy
if I was coaching Djokovic.
I mean, he's at amazing level.
But if I was to coach--
and I say never say never
about anything; I know ESPN
could be on this story--
I actually feel like
whoever it is, man or woman,
that I want to start with
them younger because you have
a chance to build,
younger meaning under 25,
and preferably in
their early 20s
that we have a chance
to grow together,
and you have a
chance to maybe make
a few subtle changes that
when they're older maybe not.
But I promise you, if I was
coaching Djokovic right now,
I'd just be kicking back.
Life would be good.
You'd just rock up every
day, probably say as little
as possible, not
screw things up.
Same like Serena.
Life is good.
She never loses.
But it would be
a player younger.
There's a couple of
incredible young-- right
now is an exciting
time in the men's game
because obviously we have
the established players,
but we got some
incredible young players.
I like to do the nicknames.
There's one guy
named Borna Coric.
I call him Borna Identity
Coric, a young Croatian
kid that's going to be great.
Kyrgios from Australia,
Zverev from Germany.
So there's an exciting
time with teenagers
that I believe the next few
years, one of these teenagers
is going to be the next guy.
And I think the same thing that
Serena is probably-- things
are going to change over.
But it would
definitely be somebody
that's late teens, early 20s.
AUDIENCE: As you were talking,
I was thinking a little bit
about maximizing opportunity,
maximizing time, particularly.
I played tennis growing
up and in college,
and the warm-up
always seemed to me
like this is my time to
scout out my opponent,
especially I didn't
have the option
to really know what's
their weakness, what's
their strength, can they move,
can they hit an overhead,
whatever it was.
And I'm just curious-- did you
have any strategies, especially
now as an amateur and not
having that option anymore,
when you have the 5-minute,
maybe 10-minute warm-up
things to do to start moving
and have one step in front
of your opponent?
STEVE JAMISON: Page 43.
BRAD GILBERT: I'm
going to promise you
I'm going to just
give you a golf clap.
I happened to be doing
a Skype the other day
with a girl that
I'm working with,
this very talented 14-year-old.
When I first hit the road
when I was 19 playing in Asia,
beyond a cellphone,
a computer, if you
got a fax that had
the "Herald Tribune,"
that was three days of reading.
So you literally had to do
all your scouting yourself,
and I would write
and make notes.
But now, you can go to YouTube
and get a little clip almost
on anybody.
So she was asking
me about, OK, I
don't know anything
about my player
that I'm playing against.
And I brought up, then
your match completely
starts in the warm-up.
Hit every ball to one
side in the warm-up
to see if all of a
sudden she runs around,
if she prefers the
forehand, the backhand.
Kind of screw your warm-up a
little bit to find out what she
likes, what she doesn't.
It's kind of like, OK, that's
your quick way to scout.
If you hit the ball
down the middle,
does she take it
on the forehand,
on the backhand?
I really think that knowledge,
because so many players
are talented.
It's funny.
I've worked with some players
that they absorb knowledge
or they're afraid of knowledge.
And sometimes, to me, when
you're afraid of knowledge,
you don't want to know
your opponent's strengths
and weaknesses.
I kind of cringe
and I'm like, why?
Why wouldn't you want to know
your opponent's strengths
and weaknesses, that maybe now
what you can do can maximize?
And obviously, sometimes
at the highest level,
and even at lower
levels, somebody
does something that you
don't think they do.
They might have that one day
where they hit a purple patch.
But in general, if
you have a thought
that they don't do
something that well,
it probably will
come to fruition.
So in a five-minute
warm-up, I even
told a lady not too long ago
in a-- she's a 4.0 player.
You know what 4.0 player is?
Because she was
telling me how much she
gets nervous all the time.
And I say, believe
it or not, your feet
are completely
connected to your brain,
and the first thing when
you get nervous is your feet
start to go, and you
make bad decisions.
So you get the happy
feet, get on your feet,
and just think about-- maybe
hum a song in your head,
but just tell yourself what
you think their weakness is
and find that.
Find the weakness, whatever
it is that you think it is.
And in the warm-up,
like you said,
if you don't know a player,
hit every ball to one side
to find out what side and
how do they react to that?
STEVE JAMISON: What's
a purple patch?
BRAD GILBERT: A purple patch?
You don't know what
a purple patch is?
STEVE JAMISON: I have
not heard that phrase.
Do you know what
a purple patch is?
AUDIENCE: No.
STEVE JAMISON: What
is a purple patch?
You said "hit a purple patch."
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like a bruise.
BRAD GILBERT: No, no.
Actually, it's an English
term when you're in fuego.
You're on fire.
You can't miss.
STEVE JAMISON: All right.
BRAD GILBERT: I didn't
get that that often,
but I've heard it
in cricket, too.
STEVE JAMISON: So
it's like in the zone.
You get in the zone.
Purple patch.
AUDIENCE: I believe you
coached Roddick at some point.
Is that correct?
BRAD GILBERT: I did, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So this question's
about Roddick.
So number one, I wanted to know
what your favorite coaching
moment was for with Roddick.
And number two, I wanted
to ask you your opinion why
that second Grand
Slam for Roddick
was so elusive outside of
Federer competing with him?
BRAD GILBERT: My
favorite Roddick moment,
believe it or not, was
the first day on the job.
Well, first, when
he called the house,
Zoe wa-- so this was the-- god,
I'm getting old-- 12 years ago.
Zoe was seven.
No, five.
Zoe was five.
He called the house, and
this is Andy Roddick.
Can I speak to your dad?
And she goes, he's
in the garden,
and she just hung up on him.
Zoe hung up on him
twice until she actually
went outside and told Kim that
some guy called a couple times,
and I was like, yeah, maybe
I want to take that call.
So I got on a plane
literally the next day
to start coaching Andy
at Queens in 2003.
And to that point, he had
never won a match on grass.
And he told me that Queens
and Wimbledon was a throwaway,
that when we get to the hard
court in the States, then
you could see what I can do.
I was kind of
scratching my head.
I was like, I don't understand.
You serve huge.
You're going to
be fine on grass.
He goes, no.
I've never won a match on grass.
We'll wait until we
get to-- he was already
talking about Indianapolis,
which was seven weeks away,
and I'm really struggling
to understand this concept
that you're focusing
on seven weeks
away when we're three days
away from the start of Queens.
And I'm like, you know what?
You're going to win
this tournament,
and you're going
to show yourself
that you can play on grass.
He says, no, no, no.
I don't win matches on grass.
So sure enough, that
tournament, he beat three guys
that he had never beaten before,
and he won that tournament
at Queens.
And then at the end
of the tournament,
he says, well, Indianapolis
can wait now a little bit.
So that was actually my
favorite Roddick moment
that I got him believing that
if you're a tennis player,
you're going to be
good on anything,
but if you believe
that you're not,
it will affect you incredibly.
STEVE JAMISON: You played
tennis, you coached tennis,
you do great coverage on tennis.
Which do you like best?
BRAD GILBERT: I'd like
to think of-- I'm 53.
I'm almost 54 years old.
I'm still a long ways
from figuring it out.
I enjoy that in my
entire adult life,
that I've got to do tennis,
and I'm still learning.
I love all aspects.
I can't go back to playing.
I play all the time, but
I'm not the same guy.
So obviously, now I love
coaching, I love doing TV,
but more than anything, I
just enjoy the chance to do
something that I really enjoy.
STEVE JAMISON: Who
are you coaching now?
Do you do it on an ad hoc basis?
BRAD GILBERT: Mrs. G over
there, Kim Gilbert, people
email her all the time, and I
work with different players.
STEVE JAMISON: Would you
work with a hacker, just
a 4.0 player?
If they said I'd like a
lesson, what would you charge?
BRAD GILBERT: Believe it
or not, I do it a lot.
So often, people will
write back a letter to Kim
because she makes it
all happen, and they
can't believe that
when I'm on the court
that I'm going to give
them the same love
and intensity as anybody.
And my whole goal is
if I'm on the court--
a lot of people,
husbands or wives,
they get gifts for their spouse.
The coolest thing.
I just was on the court.
A guy works-- Dan Simon, he's
the CNN guy for San Francisco,
and his wife got him
the birthday gift.
I'm on the court,
and he can't believe
that I'm actually working on
his game and spending the time.
And it's like I'm on
the court with somebody,
I'm going to try to help you
and try to understand your game.
The one thing that I
learned from coaching,
when I was coaching Roddick,
I'm not coaching Agassi.
When I'm coaching Andy Murray,
I'm coaching Andy Murray.
So when I'm on the
court with somebody,
I'm not thinking
about somebody else.
I'm thinking about what we
can do to look at their game
to improve.
So I did this thing
yesterday for Har-Tru
and a lady named Kim, and
she was holding a racket down
at her waist.
And I'm like, you've got to
protect your Will and Grace.
You've got to put
the racket in front
of your nose a
little bit, and so we
were working on her volley.
She had never been told that.
So we did a little thing
working on holding a racket.
Sp I always feel like
there's something
we can work on, something that
we can help them get better.
And I enjoy that process
as much as anything,
trying to help
people get better.
STEVE JAMISON: I know you like
to teach, which is coaching,
but you have this
amazing fascination
with how the game works.
That's why you were saying-- I
didn't know you liked cricket.
BRAD GILBERT: I love cricket.
STEVE JAMISON: But
whatever the sport,
you view it like a
watchmaker views a watch.
You just love the dynamics
of it and the mechanics of it
and everything about it.
BRAD GILBERT: I'm
not pseudotechnical.
There are some
coaches in some sports
that are super technical.
And one of my all
time pet peeves
is hearing a coach that
has one philosophy--
it's my way or the highway--
and he's not adaptable.
To me, I'm adaptable
to the player.
I mean, if you have
a system, but you
don't have any players
that can play the system,
you're in a lot of trouble.
So I like to think
of whatever sport
it is, I start thinking to
myself, if I was playing
that sport, how would I do it?
What would be my niche in it?
I like that facet of sports.
STEVE JAMISON: I know that.
AUDIENCE: At the end
of Agassi's career,
his knees were a
little shot, I think.
BRAD GILBERT: No, his hips.
AUDIENCE: Was it his hips?
Well, you hear about
Nadal and people
with all kinds of
health problems.
Federer on the other hand,
like you said, amazing health.
He's obviously doing
something right.
Are people learning
lessons from Federer
or learning how to keep
themselves healthy better
as time goes on?
BRAD GILBERT: It's a
great question in sports.
There's more done now on
research and everything.
But there's no
foolproof way that you
can keep yourself healthy
when you're pushing yourself
to the limit.
I do think for some
reason with Roger,
I told you his socks don't get
dirty, but believe it or not,
I had a pair of his shoes
last year at Wimbledon.
We had them on set,
and me being crazy,
I started looking
at his shoes, and I
noticed something incredible.
He has all-time Fred
Flintstone feet.
STEVE JAMISON: Which is what?
BRAD GILBERT: His
shoe size-- well, he's
got a 12 for his size,
but he had a quadruple E.
He's got the widest, thickest
feet you've ever seen,
like Fred Flintstone.
Maybe that's why he's got this--
STEVE JAMISON: It's a base.
BRAD GILBERT: Nothing
else is that big,
but he's got these
massive, wide, thick feet.
So maybe that's why
he's got the good base.
But there is no
foolproof science.
You're hearing these
football players that
sleep in hyperbaric chambers,
and you do all this stuff
to prevent injuries.
Some of it is luck,
some of it's your DNA.
Roger, the one thing that he
does maybe an amazing job,
he paces his schedule.
When he thinks he's
going to play a block,
he plays that block,
doesn't change from it,
and then goes from when
it's time to train.
Nadal's style, it's
like a running back.
It's like you see
him and you think,
it takes more physical
exertion the way he plays.
You see Nadal when he's playing.
He's in a full lather
sweat five minutes in.
So part of it's your
DNA, too, but to tell you
that somebody has some
magic formula how you're not
going to get hurt, a lot
of football teams who spend
zillions, basketball
teams, baseball teams
spend zillions to keep
their guys healthy,
and they want to know why.
Sometimes it really is, I swear
to god, this ugly word to say,
it's luck.
STEVE JAMISON: You
mentioned football teams.
Is it true the 49ers are
doomed this coming season?
Or would you rather
talk about Oakland?
BRAD GILBERT: We are
in 49er country here.
STEVE JAMISON: I know it.
Give us some good news.
BRAD GILBERT: Some good news.
OK, I'll be the eternal
optimist that they got rid
of a coach that was an
unbelievable gift for them,
and they replaced
him with an unknown.
But you know what?
Now it's time for the players
and time for everybody
to figure out that
you know what?
Everybody's selling us short.
No one thinks we
can do anything.
So instead of
having that attitude
that we're going down--
they call it in Australia
down the gurgler.
You're going down the tubes.
That you know what?
We have a chance to make
things happen and get better.
And so don't buy into that
we're going down the gurgler.
STEVE JAMISON: That's not a
very optimistic message, Brad.
BRAD GILBERT: Vegas has
it that their over/under
win total is about six.
STEVE JAMISON: OK.
I don't know what that
means, but is that good?
BRAD GILBERT: You
know what that is?
That's at 6 and 10.
STEVE JAMISON: OK.
That's our optimistic
message about the 49ers.
BRAD GILBERT: That's better
than they have for the Raiders
at four and a half.
STEVE JAMISON: OK.
BRAD GILBERT: Right here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Brad.
My name is Kishore
and this question
is from my brother's
son, who is 13 and 1/2
and is playing under 14 within
the top 100 in the country
right now.
So his question is I think
he's at a crossroads.
He feels he's at a
crossroads because he's
getting into high
school and spending
I think around four days
a week practicing tennis
in the evenings and
paying tournaments
in weekends at the same time the
academic pressure is coming in.
And if he doesn't play
those tournaments,
he's going to fall behind in
rankings, and the pressure
of having to come back up.
So the question
is, I'm sure this
is common for a lot of people,
and you kind of touched upon
that earlier.
So what is your advice
to somebody like this?
BRAD GILBERT: First of all,
I thought at about nine
we end the halves because it
was always like the 7 and 1/2,
8 and 1/2, but 13
and 1/2, I like that.
There is no such thing in life
at 13 and 1/2 as a crossroads.
Honest to god, I would tell
you that's alarming in itself
to hear the stress
of somebody saying
that I'm at a crossroads.
Tennis is a game that you can
play for the rest of your life.
And you know what?
It's a vehicle that can
help you in everything.
But that's the very first
thing that I would say.
You're not at a crossroads.
Don't think of it
as a crossroads.
What do you want to accomplish?
What do we want to
do and get better at?
What's our goal for high school?
Maybe if I'm stressing
playing the tournaments
on the weekends, maybe we
can invest a little more time
and maybe less time
playing tournaments,
or figure out a
different schedule,
but take out that crossroads.
That's a bullshit
word for a 13 and 1/2
year old because that's
only putting more pressure,
and it's setting
himself up for a fall.
At 13 and 1/2, there's no
reason to have any type of fall.
Life is fun.
It gets hard when you're an
adult, but at 13 and 1/2,
life is fun.
You shouldn't feel any
stress or pressure.
And I do see it
more now than ever,
and I see it more now from
parents stressing kids
that they have to be at
this level of expectations
that they want.
The first thing when I do coach
a kid, I always want to know,
does he want to be good
because he wants it,
not because his parents or
not because somebody else.
So I want to know that the
passion comes from him,
and we work with that.
That's the most important
thing is finding out
how passionate he is and
where is it coming from,
and talk about the
positives, and no crossroads.
That's not a word
for a kid whatsoever.
STEVE JAMISON: When you're doing
worldwide ESPN coverage live,
have you ever slipped like
that and used a bad word?
A curse word like you just did?
No?
BRAD GILBERT: I
have not got called
in the principal's office.
STEVE JAMISON: That's
all we need to know.
That's all we need to know.
BRAD GILBERT: I think,
though, in December
when I did seven
weeks of radio, they
have a 3-second
delay for the live.
I think I popped a 3-second
delay, but I'm pretty good.
I sometimes bite
my tongue if I'm
going to say something stupid.
STEVE JAMISON:
Didn't you tell me
that they want you to
stay just basically
like you are, and
they don't even
call you in for the
precoverage meetings
and say, do this,
do this, do this.
BRAD GILBERT: I go to meetings.
STEVE JAMISON: Do you?
BRAD GILBERT: One
thing about TV--
STEVE JAMISON: You
go to meetings.
BRAD GILBERT: --there's
a lot of meetings.
STEVE JAMISON: OK.
BRAD GILBERT: There's a lot
more meetings and stuff going on
than you'd ever think.
But I've never studied
myself, I never
went to seminars or
whatever, and they
do want me to be myself and
not try to overthink it.
I think about when I'm
on air, the one thing
is it's like talking
on a telephone.
I tell you what, speak
of the telephone,
young people don't
even have a land line.
You ask people,
what's your land line?
Excuse me?
Everybody's got a cellphone.
That's it.
So that's how I think about it.
I don't get nervous I
don't overanalyze it.
I don't stress it.
I just try to enjoy it.
STEVE JAMISON: You've
been good from the start,
although I think Kim Gilbert has
got you looking a lot better.
BRAD GILBERT: Kim Gilbert
picks out all my clothes.
STEVE JAMISON:
You're looking good.
AUDIENCE: I'm glad you could
make it down here, Brad.
I've been waiting to see you
down here for a couple years.
But given that you have
a good mind for tennis
and you evaluate talent
pretty well, when
the so-called big four in
the men's game is gone,
who do you see as maybe the
next dominant male player
on the horizon?
BRAD GILBERT: It's
a great question.
You know, if you'd asked
me after Andre and Pete,
I would have told
you there's no way
that we were going to have a
dominant player right away.
I would have thought
we might have
had a five-year period where
it would have been a push
and pull that maybe a
few different guys would
make a move maybe.
But obviously, it
changed, immediately how
dominant Fed came, and then
outrageously then came Nadal,
and now we're going
through it with Djocovic.
I think we have some incredible
teenagers, but like I said,
I think Coric, I think Kyrgios
have incredible talent.
I'm hopeful the
American, Francis Tiafoe.
There's another
Australian, Kokkinakis.
German named Zverev.
But to say that somebody
winning one or a few to becoming
a dominant one is a
whole other animal,
and there hasn't been
that many, so I don't like
to put that label on somebody.
If you ask me and say, OK,
this guy's got a chance
to be a great player, but to be
the next Nadal, the next Fed,
that's a big label
to put on somebody.
And what happens to
a lot of players--
I told this to our
Canada friend--
and what happens is expectations
on young players sometimes
can just wear them down.
And some have the ability to
take expectations and embrace
it like nobody and they
actually get better for it
because they like it.
To me, how I define absolute
greatness, when somebody says,
how do you see it?
How you know it?
When I watch a
Michael Jordan, when
I watch a Kobe, when I
watch a Fed, Nadal, a Tom
Brady, at the highest level,
when other people will say
things are going a million
miles an hour, for them,
it actually slows down to where
it actually becomes absolutely
clear what they're going to do.
And that is the 0000%.
You need obviously the
genius athleticism,
but those are the
athletic prowess, to me.
When it's 100 all
on a basketball game
and Michael Jordan's clear
at what he's going to do,
that is so rare.
That's what you see from Fed.
That, to me, is
the clearest thing
that I've ever
seen of greatness,
that things slow down for them
for the same other person that
maybe is close in
talent, that it speeds up
and they make a bad decision.
STEVE JAMISON: That's good.
I'll just close with this.
I interviewed you right after
you teamed up with Andre.
He was 28 or 29,
as you mentioned.
I said, can you get Andre
to number one in the world?
And you said, I can
get him to number two.
After that, it's up to Andre.
And it goes to something inside.
There's an intangible
at that highest level
that you can get them
here, but then they've
got to get to that final
rung on the ladder.
BRAD GILBERT: I've
seen in a lot of sports
that athletically
or skill set wise,
they have it to get to
where you think you can,
but then there's a lot
of things sometimes
that that last step is more
than a lot of different things
and how you handle all that.
Sometimes that one step is a
lot bigger than one step, man.
It's like football fields.
STEVE JAMISON: You had a
great career as a player
with one exception.
Lendl beat you 19 times
in a row and you told me--
BRAD GILBERT: Why you
got to make it worse?
It was only 16.
STEVE JAMISON: 16.
OK.
He beat you 16 times in a
row, and you were so mad
that you didn't get a chance
to play him for the 17th time.
Why was that?
BRAD GILBERT: The 16th
time I'm playing him,
I'm at Philly at the
old Spectrum Arena,
and every time I
played him, I always
felt like Freddy Krueger.
I mean, the guy just
could not be killed.
The first 10 times,
he just waxed me.
But for some reason, this
was in '91 in Philly.
I had this feeling for
the first time walking out
I wasn't uptight, actually
had a sense of calmness.
And I said to myself for the
first time-- I couldn't even
believe I said it to myself.
I was like, I'm going to beat
this-- I said a bad word.
I'm going to beat
this guy tonight.
And for the first time,
things were slowing down,
and I actually felt really
good about my chances.
Little did I know in the second
set, somehow I rolled my foot,
and it was killing me.
I knew that somehow, I've
got to get through this.
I was up 4-1, double
break in the third.
I got a game point,
and I really started
thinking about all
the times that he
had given me a lot of
grief in the locker room.
That's it.
I'm going to be able
to shake his hand,
and say I finally got him.
And so I got ahead of
myself a little bit.
I choked the easiest volley
on top of the net for 5-1
in the third.
I go on to lose
7-5 in the third.
I'm sitting in the locker
room with three bags
of ice on my foot.
I ended up being
out about 10 weeks.
I had a little stress
fracture on my foot.
Lendl comes over with his
normal Lendl sense of humor
and he said to me, if
I had 110 temperature,
and I was on my deathbed, I
wasn't losing to you tonight.
STEVE JAMISON: Thank you, Brad.
BRAD GILBERT: Got to love it.
[APPLAUSE]